watching some more five minute crafts
please let's hope some of these are
medically accurate like at least one
huge thanks to nordvpn for sponsoring
this video let's get started
what is this inflatable thing used for
okay okay no no no no no no no no no no
no ain't no way ain't no way she's
sleeping like I just don't buy it ain't
no way this guy is cool with sleeping
with a unicorn inflatable Nexus like
I've heard of sleep divorces and I'm
sure that's how they happen why is he
sleeping with one hand in his pocket
awkwardly like that I don't know what
that is awkward sleeping position man
lower back fatigue ball
exercise ball bouncy ball okay okay
actually I'm not a fan and bear knows
this of the giant medicine balls as a
thing to do all day at work because what
happens is you fatigue your back even
more you stress it out you cause muscle
spasms you essentially are taking an
undertrained back and forcing it to run
a marathon does that seem smart not
really five minute crafts okay there's a
cactus on her belly that she rubbed she
laughed she also rubs it what kind of
office space is this that they're just
rubbing cacti is there like a culture
where rubbing a cactus is good luck like
a rabbit's foot or something she takes a
pen
she opens the pen
what is happening first of all where is
she getting all these pen caps from
that's a hack to stop people from
rubbing your belly what about like a
lawsuit
because like people shouldn't come up
and just rub your tummy at work okay
jeans that don't fit it happens
you fold them oh is that a pregnancy tip
you just fold them over and walk I mean
I don't know if that's a tip my buttons
don't close I guess I'll just leave it
open life hack okay she's struggling
with steps which is reasonable if
someone has back pain
so now she's going to give herself some
added support I have no idea how that
helped her walk up the steps and her
acting is absolutely terrible she's
never winning an Emmy with that kind of
performance but if you want to give
yourself a little support I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna hate okay we got a belly
here a sneeze okay oh when you sneeze or
cough or anytime you increase
intra-abdominal pressure you can
inadvertently release some urine her
friend is laughing and being judgmental
uh that's not nice
um what is she gonna do what is she
gonna do cross her legs
and she didn't because she crossed her
legs okay I have a good friend uh Dr
vyas who's a a pelvic floor rehab
specialist from PM R which is physical
medicine and rehabilitation they can
literally teach you how to strengthen
your pelvic floor to have better control
so I rather you have the exercises and
strength in the area rather than use a
hack
she's hot so she puts her bras in the
freezer I saw the Cabbage thing before
and I thought I saw it all I mean if
you're that hot I guess that's something
but you could just use like a pack these
hacks have gone from inaccurate just
mostly useless and ridiculous Orbeez
okay wait four hours okay so you have
giant orbs these are like marbles or
something two Ziploc bags you freeze
them and then let it froze let it froze
okay Frozen Orbeez oh right on the
breast I'm gonna make a statement on
this channel whatever object that is
non-toxic non-dangerous to humans or
others that you would enjoy freezing and
placing to give you comfort is probably
okay
I've seen the Cabbage I've seen the
clothes the bras now the Orbeez what
happened to good old-fashioned peas just
don't do this with meat by the way
because when you defrost the meat and
then freeze it again the bacteria can
actually multiply and grow and it can
become a problem she trying to reach for
a book she can't
he's a gentleman and he is oh he's
trying to guess what she wants instead
of just asking is this a lesson on how
to not communicate with your partner wow
that guy is a
prick what is he
did my guy really say I don't want to
pick out the book that you want so
here's a vacuum cleaner so suck the book
out it was easier for him to go across
to the other side of the room and pick
out the vacuum bro only five minute
crafts okay we got some sniffles fever
it seems okay what do we get oh we got
an onion you know what that means I
don't but five minute crafts knows let's
see she's gonna take a nap
wait what is the hack what does it do
what is the promise I don't understand
onion and fever they don't go together
so hot that's me at night actually let's
see what the tip is okay she's very
sweaty very sweaty I understand the
struggle okay we get it you were
sweating let's get the hack
the freezer
bro it should just be called five minute
crafts freezer Edition so now it's
frozen and hard what are you gonna do
now and how long do you think it stays
cool with your body temperature heating
it up it's gonna have literal ice on it
because you sweat into it and then you
froze it and then you're gonna lay on
Ice all night you think that's good for
your skin direct contact with ice no
frostbite irritation back to the crafts
in just a second but first I want to
talk to you about nordvpn a service that
protects your internet connection and
privacy online when I'm traveling
outside the US that means a lot of the
shows and movies I would normally stream
are no longer available but when I use
nordvpn I could set my location to the
US so I can have streaming access to my
shows like I'm sitting at home on my
couch nordvpn creates an encrypted
tunnel for your data protects your
online identity by hiding your IP
address and allows you to use public
Wi-Fi hotspots safely Nord is not just a
simple VPN though but also offers threat
protection a malware block without
additional costs for a limited time and
you won't have to worry about speed
because the tests have proved it nordvpn
is the fastest VPN on the market
compatibility won't be an issue either
as nordvpn runs on Windows Android iOS
Mac OS Linux even your Android TV for
the holiday season they've also got a
great deal right now where you can get
four months free when you sign up for a
two-year plan to get started all you
have to do is visit nordvpn.com Dr Mike
remember doctor is spelled out and try
it risk-free right now with a 30-day
money-back guarantee it's so easy and it
just takes one click all right let's get
back to these ridiculous crafts okay
we're washing feet we're washing feet
using the other foot okay was that a
hack to show how to wash feet if you
can't reach your feet that's the same
thing that you do when you wash your
hands when you wash your hands do you
wash one hand at a time no you go high
hand mean hand number two
look Washi Washi so you do the same
thing with your feet how is is that a
hack thirsty
then swallow
whoa science
this guy has really cool blue eyes I
feel like they're digitally enhanced
though okay what does she got shoes he
has a shoe wait why did he take off his
shoe okay wait he took a shoe and he
he's making his shoe are they shoes to
help your feet dry how is that any
better than what was happening already
I'm so confused that hack took longer
than any benefit that it brought to you
a hack has to maximize benefit I'm
treating this like a FDA approved this
item has to have proven benefit and
known and limited risks there was no
benefit to that one okay bathroom issue
standing issue okay that can happen it
is hard I understand especially if
you've hurt your low back like if you
have sciatica well in that case we do
put yeah we we give patients things like
this this is all accessibility like we
have a home nurse that can come to your
home make adjustments make safety
recommendations with rails guard rails
all of these things this is probably the
first 5 min to craft I cosine okay cell
phones vibrating emails are coming in
overwhelmed feeling stress ball oh what
are we gonna do stress ball foot massage
it's not a hack to say go get a massage
that's you buying an item to massage
yourself because you enjoy massages it's
not a hack God imagine you get that much
joy from rolling a little spiky ball on
your foot I wonder what her rating is on
wikiFeet last we checked what was my
rating
this person is feeling hot on the beach
so they put on a foot pad to walk on the
beach okay my friend actually made an
item like this for dogs called paw
Savers it's quite similar but just for
dogs I just don't say how this is a hack
versus them selling an item does she
have a Wi-Fi signal what was that she
just put what what is she she put four
Band-Aids on her mouth won't snore again
snoring doesn't come from your lips
snoring comes from
the oral pharynx not this who snores
like
you snore
that's what sleep apnea is that's what
snoring is dangerous because it's
literally your Airway closing because
the airway relaxes and the muscles relax
when you fall asleep so they can
potentially close off and that's why you
wake up and then you don't get a good
quality Rest full sleep okay we have
socks with holes okay we're gonna double
sock why would you double up now your
feet are gonna sweat extra and then
you're gonna get a fungal infection on
your toe and you're gonna come see me
and I'm gonna tell you that if you use
the topical treatment it can take up to
48 weeks to work and it may not even
work all the time but if I give you an
oral treatment it'll take about 12 weeks
to work it'll have a better success of
working there's a side effect of
potentially causing liver inflammation
leading to liver enzyme elevation which
I would have to follow with blood tests
before and at the six week Mark and
you're gonna have to make a decision all
that from an extra sock oh
okay we have a person who's getting
motion sick they're they're struggling
in the back seat they're gonna count oh
no they're gonna tuck their finger okay
distraction methods for motion sickness
can work but I will say if it doesn't
don't be disappointed because in the
majority of cases that's not the
solution trouble sleeping all the time
tired and wired that's my situation okay
onions reduce stress levels by smelling
are you kidding me if I smell an onion
before going to sleep that's going to
reduce my sh I'm going to want to leave
the bedroom if it smells like onions I'm
gonna feel like bear farted if I smell
onions okay more motion sickness poor
girl still in this car trapped okay
she's loosening her hair tie she's
putting on a bracelet she got a potato
go they've upgraded from the onion
honestly if you are motion sick and you
start worrying about whether or not you
have a potato that can distract you so
much because your head's going to be so
confused while you're looking for a
potato that it might just cure your
motion sickness and we got an allergy I
don't know if that looks like an allergy
to me that looks more like maculopapular
rash or perhaps some rosacea or acne
let's see what their recommendation is
all right some makeup allergy check okay
okay do not do your own skin testing at
home please leave it to us in the
medical community if anything we can
deduce it from the history of what
you're allergic to and if we need to we
can do proper skin testing so it's
objective it's accurate okay if a person
whose leg fell asleep from sitting
cross-legged spasm oh they have a spasm
with x-ray vision she's gonna rub rub on
her toe and if you rub on your toe
that's good luck and spasms can go away
with good luck I promise rubbing toes
does not relieve spasms in your calf
like I could even see if they said if
you had anterior Shin pain and you rub
the area around your your thumb that
could help because at least the tibialis
anterior attaches to the thumb so maybe
you could say if you're rubbing the
attachment you're doing something but
they're rubbing the top part of your
foot and then your area is on the back
of your leg that's spazzled they're not
even connected okay what are we doing
here laughing laughing laughing laughing
laughing falling
tripping
oh that's one big bruise to get on a
carpet from taking three steps okay
deodorant stops bleeding okay first of
all your body stops the bleeding on a
cut like this all I would do is wash it
out with some warm water maybe some mild
soap no deodorant alcohol no peroxide
all of that's going to just irritate the
area further you don't need any of that
and that bandage I don't care that it
has an emoji on it but you're putting
the sticky part on the scabs you know
how uncomfortable that is that's one of
the worst videos she's acting she
deserves an Oscar my teeth hurt probably
time to go to the dentist
sugar-free baby food is that sugar-free
baby food there's mango there mango has
sugar there's no sugar added but there's
sugar there freeze okay
and now what those are frozen fruit
snacks those still have sugar those
still have sugar
oh I hate when you hit your knee on the
corner of a table that's so painful oh
or the elbow and you get that funny bone
by the way the funny Bone's not a funny
bone it's an ulnar nerve or the ulnar
nerve Groove that you hit that's why it
sends that signal because it's like it's
a weird pain nerve pain is unique it's
different than any other pain that's why
when doctors ask you describe the pain
we're not just like looking for a number
we're looking for the type of pain is it
aching is it dull is it stabbing is it
shooting is it throbbing is it electric
electric pain can be nerve pain
throbbing pain can be artery related
pain like an aneurysm all those things
point us to a conclusion sponge
I feel like a freezer is coming
bunch
wait a sponge that's not even cold bro
you just what it you wiped off
bruise brushing teeth pimple oh
Whitehead whoa that pimple just grew in
size okay what is the dry skin coming
from
distilled water orange oil oh my God
don't do this medicinal herbs medicinal
herbs no explanation what the herbs are
this looks like cheese I'm not gonna lie
this looks like shredded cheddar just
like we have ingredients that are proven
to do certain things that are tested
dermatologically why would you do this
with questionable medicinal herbs where
do you even go and buy medicinal herbs
yesterday I had a patient that broke out
in a terrible contact dermatitis
chemical irritin dermatite is probably
from like one of these types of facials
needed oral steroids it was that bad
actually okay you're gonna get a tan
with those things on yeah that's not
healthy either you're gonna get increase
your risk of skin cancer by doing that I
also feel like that's a spray tan
cool suntan how is that a cool nothing
about that was cool oh that's uh that
looks like a fungal infection athlete's
foot but the mom
knows what to do with a balloon
that's literally the worst thing you can
do for athlete's foot you just made the
child sweat double the amount decrease
air circulation and have increased the
risk for worsening athlete's foot
congratulations five minute crafts
you've made your child look absolutely
ridiculous like they have balloon toes
and have worsened their medical
condition okay we have a modeling
exhibition of sorts a fashion show heels
with a Band-Aid
oh so judgmental please help I have a
Band-Aid
oh marker what is she drawing a toenail
whoa whoa whoa
are they saying the Band-Aid becomes
invisible because you painted on it I
don't have great vision so maybe it
might fool me from a distance
security yes no is it a height thing
okay so she's in the no section which is
fine because that's for safety you get a
mat walk on the mat
you cut out pieces of a mat to add to
the bottom of your shoe to make you
taller so that you can go where taller
people are allowed to go first of all
who has security with paper stuck to
their chest and hat you really think
that's better sir the purpose of having
you must be tall to ride this ride is
because of safety so no never do this
never do this five minute craft
this person stubbed their toe or it's
hot always hot
that can happen
okay pool noodle let's see the solution
[Music]
it hurts my soul
flip flop I know some people might say
what if she doesn't have the money to
get a flip-flop she does she's by a very
expensive pool there's a very beautiful
home behind her there's a flip-flop
available even if it's not her style
because I promise the style will be
better than cutting off a pool noodle
which also costs money getting blue
painters duct tape and then sticking it
onto your feet and then not being able
to take it off and then when you come
out wet the tape won't stick I'm getting
really offended by a pool noodle life
hack this is when you know you've gone
too far
click here to see how coffee truly
affects your body click it and once
again huge thank you to nordvpn for
sponsoring this video as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]